so I must have found the dedicated
front-end developers to be here 9:00
a.m. when John skeet is talking y'all
are I you're all heroes I really
appreciate you being here I hope I will
make it worth your while this is a
subject very near and dear to my heart
that I've suffered through a lot of pain
blood sweat and tears
put together material like this
incidentally how I'm assuming all of you
do some degree of front-end if you're
here how many of you do angularjs or
angular at all okay okay great
because I'll the last third of this talk
is pretty in the weeds of angularjs -
angular so I was gonna temper it
accordingly how many of you are either
starting a migration or in the middle of
a migration I figured if you're
dedicated enough to come to the first
session on the last day then that's what
I love about these these migration talks
is it's a very like guttural visceral
experience to have to migrate a big
habit so no matter the size of the crowd
it's always a very emotional subject and
that's very effective so I'm glad you're
here
so we're gonna talk about modernizing
large front ends with web components
alternative title making new shiny
things work with old dusty things so I I
live in the northwest corner of America
and I live on a plot of land in the
middle of a forest and my primary source
of heat is this wood stove here and so
every morning for about six months of
the year I have to build a fire to heat
my house and in making hundreds of these
fires day after day I've learned this
valuable lesson that the type of
kindling and the way I arrange the
kindling at the start of the morning
determines the life of the fire for the
rest of the day basically the the
starting point of building the fire
I can keep it going if I do it right I
can keep it going as long as I want cuz
I've got the right bed of coals and I'm
just dorky enough of a person to
extrapolate lessons about software
development from fire building and and
so I draw a lot of parallels to that
with large-scale reef actors come for
the Tech Talks stay for the fire
building tips but the thing about
large-scale reef actors are very
difficult and messy and complex and the
interesting thing is the figuring out
the architecture from the beginning is
the most important step because it ends
up determining a lot of what follows and
you might make mistakes down the road
that are difficult to come back from so
that's that's what we're going to talk
about today in in different in different
sub terrain so I'm Sam julene I am a
senior developer advocate engineer which
is a very long title for basically
developer relations at auth0 were a
identity management and basically
identity as a service company focusing
on the authentication authorization this
talk has nothing to do with that today
because my other passion is angular and
angularjs upgrades and things like that
I'm also an angular Google developer
expert and part of this collaborators
program for angular where I work with
the angular team and sort of have a sort
of part of the outer circle of the
angular team basically not a Googler but
work with them and then I care so much
about ng upgrade that I built this
massive video course on it called
upgrading angularjs comm that's all
about ng upgrade specifically not
angular elements what we're talking
about today I also make videos for think
stir which is another platform and
egghead and like I said I live on a
small organic farm in the rural Pacific
Northwest of America so what we're gonna
do today this morning is a sort of a a
series of zooms in on this subject we're
gonna start at a very high level and
zoom our way in so there's three
sections of this we've got
sort of just abroad like laying the
foundation of front-end philosophy and
evolution of front-end theirs we're they
gonna zoom in a little bit to the web
component ecosystem get a feel for what
what web components are and how they
came to be and things like that and then
we're gonna zoom in really close and
talk about specifically angular elements
for angularjs to angular so this is sort
of like the view from the plane and then
the view from the parachute and then the
view for when you crash through the roof
of the grocery store and you're in the
middle of the boxes of cereal and things
like that
so first let's just lay a little bit of
ground work on modern front ends since
this is usually more of a back-end heavy
conference more of a dotnet c-sharp II
kind of conference which is my
background as well from before I got
into front-end stuff so traditionally we
sort of had this very distinct
separation between the server and the
view layer you probably a lot of you
here are familiar with the concept of
like dotnet MVC with like razor template
it's kind of a very clear boundary
between the business logic and the view
layer and then over the last several
years these things called single page
applications came along and really kind
of messed up that whole scenario and
things got really jumbled really quickly
where it became very ambiguous where
business logic should live should it
live jumbled in with the front-end code
or still on the server and things got a
little complicated and for a lot of the
early days of single page applications
like any of you familiar with like
knockout and backbone and things like
that there's a lot of mixing of the
business logic with the templating and
things like that that made it very hard
to understand that we are that there was
a time where we really focused on Dom
manipulation you know jQuery was a huge
thing I remember working on a project
for a utility company that used jQuery
and there's a very kind of procedural
like go get this data and you
No if this financial rule is true then
add this block to the page and things
like that so that also sort of
contributed to this muddling of the
business logic in the view layer then
somewhere along the line a bunch of
people remembered functional programming
and sort of said like what if we applied
these principles of functional
programming which have been around for
decades to the front end and react was
really the first group to popularize
this at Facebook where they said like
what if we have these inputs and then we
have this render logic and then we
generate these views and that sort of
helped us come back full circle to this
idea of having the business logic and
the view layer it just became a really
different kind of scenario than we're
used to now it's more like having you
know JavaScript in api's and then your
your view layer of your JavaScript HTML
CSS maybe JSX if you're doing react the
difference is that now we sort of have
like services or or es6 classes on the
front end that are holding all of the
business logic and then in both
scenarios there's sort of this goal to
be as framework agnostic as possible and
keep things living in JavaScript if
they're on the front end that way we
avoid having to dig out of these
proprietary languages or frameworks if
the if things change which we know on
the front end change rapidly so we're
back to this idea of JavaScript and
api's which will be the business logic
and then we have the view layer and
what's nice about this is now with these
modern frameworks it becomes much easier
to switch if you've you've got angular
or maybe you're using react or next week
when component R on 2050 comes out and
we have to all switch over all of our
applications to the new JavaScript
framework if we've been practicing these
things of trying to isolate our business
logic into just plain JavaScript and use
inputs and outputs for the view layer we
should have an easier time so modern
JavaScript frameworks like angular and
react and view have a little bit more of
this philosophy basically sometimes they
look a little bit differently angular is
very object oriented react is very
heavily influenced by functional
programming but the basic idea is
roughly roughly the same and both of
them now sort of promote this idea of
not having a lot of business logic in
your views other than sort of mapping
over objects or things like that or sort
of having conditional statements things
like that so that's sort of the
ecosystem in which web components was
birthed and web components have this as
sort of a core philosophy behind them
because they're basically just plain
JavaScript in HTML at the end of the day
so what what are web components web
components are this is the definition
from Mozilla developer Network but
really all well that you need to take
away from it is that it's reusable
custom elements and then the
functionality is encapsulated away from
the rest of the code they're sort of
like these little black boxes that you
put inputs and outputs out of and nobody
needs to know what's going on inside of
them basically so before I get to the
actual code of web components and what
they look like what might be some times
that you would use these there's a few
very popular use cases for them the
first is something called micro
front-ends and this is actually probably
a very familiar pattern to you that you
didn't know had a very cool hip name to
it
for example maybe you've done something
like this where you have Microsoft CRM
or SharePoint or something like that and
you stick tiny you know jQuery
front ends or angularjs front ends or
something like that to display some data
or something you can do the same thing
with web components now basically where
you have a web component here and a web
component there and a web component
there and that's one example you could
also a micro front-end might also be a
front-end for a micro service it's a
very small self-contained front-end so
that's one use case another really
popular way to use web components is to
create shared component libraries for
your UI so for example maybe you have a
team at your company that's using react
and a team
your company that's using angular or
whatever and you want to design
different UI pieces datepicker widgets
you know whatever you can use web
components for that and then share them
in these other platforms because at the
end of the day they're just JavaScript
and HTML and CSS like everything else so
kind of a marriage of those two ideas is
the idea of using web components to
modernize old front ends and that's what
we're gonna talk about today but this is
an idea where you have your legacy code
and then you stick some web components
around and you can either use that to
write a new feature in a more modern way
or you can use it to upgrade an old
feature into a more modern way and just
slap that script tag on the page and and
you're done
it's a little more complicated than that
as you might imagine but I like to think
of web components a friend of mine in
Helsinki named Aqsa Lee gave a talk on
web components last year and he used
this phrase of a web component being
like an API for the view layer and I
thought that was a really good analogy
for this concept it sort of abstracts
away the need to know what's going on
inside of the web component and again
that lets us come back to this idea of
separating out our business logic from
our review layer so we mentioned that
the functionality being encapsulate
encapsulated away from the rest of the
code and that's what lets us move from
this like jumbled mess of Dom
manipulation and business logic all
mixed in together into this more like
separated tiny encapsulated pieces of UI
so now let's actually look at what a
custom element looks like and it's
interesting because there are there's
the first part of custom elements is
very simple and straightforward and then
as with most things in development you
dig a little bit deeper and things
they're not quite as simple as they seem
and not quite as easy to use as as you
might think so a web component or a
custom element is composed of basically
three things the first is a selector
string
basically the thing that you use for
that you put in the brackets on the page
the second is just a JavaScript class
that defines the functionality of the
component these two things are put into
something called custom elements
registry dot define which is just a
browser API and then all of these are
can also include an options object so
here's an example of what that would
look like so we have custom elements dot
define here and then in the end of that
function we pass our selector string of
my element C and we pass in our
JavaScript class of my element and then
here's our options object in this case
what we're doing here is we're extending
the P tag we can basically inherit from
another HTML tag this is optional you
don't have to do this if we do include
the the extends P tag when we put this
on the page it's going to look like this
where we use the P and we we passing
this attribute called is with our
selector string of the custom element so
that's one way that you can define a
custom element I'd say the more
prevalent way to do it is to ditch the
options object unless you need it for
something and just use your own custom
element from scratch basically and then
when we put that on the page that's
where you're used to seeing something
like this where you have my element as
the tag that you put on the page or if
you're adding it to the Dom manually you
would just add that that selector string
so that's sort of the simple easy 30
second explanation of a custom web
component and there's a lot of other
bells and whistles that you can do with
web components and that's where things
sort of get off into the weeds and get a
little bit more complicated that you can
use attributes with them as inputs that
one's pretty straightforward not much to
say they're web components also have
lifecycle methods like you're used to in
a framework like JavaScript or angular
or react or something so there's there's
four of them the first one is the
connected callback basically when the
element
is added to the page second one is the
disconnected callback when it's removed
from the page and then we have the
adopted callback where it's moved to a
new page and then lastly we have the
attribute changed callback which you
probably have guessed is when the
attributes changed pretty
straightforward so these are really nice
you can use them just like you would use
something like energy on a knit or
component did mount and react very easy
custom web components also include this
idea of the shadow Dom this is another
so this is sort of this could be a whole
subject in and of itself but a shadow
Dom is basically like a it's added to
the Dom separately and so you can
encapsulate things like styles and it
won't mess with the rest of the page so
with a custom element that's really nice
all you have to do is call this attach
shadow and there's some options you can
pass into it and the browser will just
add this new I'm being careful not to
say virtual Dom which is the concept in
react because it's a slightly different
thing but if you but you can think of it
like a virtual Dom it's technically not
the same but it's the idea is is
basically the same where you have this
sort of like sandbox Dom that doesn't
affect the Dom on the rest of the page
and you can do that react uses this for
diffing and things like that again
there's a lot you can get into on the
shadow Dom so I recommend you go read
about it similarly there's this concept
of HTML templates also another very
cutting-edge feature and this is also
very similar to things you've seen in
bigger frameworks there's these new
things called templates and slots that
you can basically use reusable templates
that are rendered given a set of inputs
like I mentioned earlier and this is
another thing you can go off into the
weeds and read all about so things like
the shadow DOM and templating start to
make this a bit more complicated as
you're trying to write them on your own
and part of the reason that makes this
more complicated as we all familiar with
on the front end is this whole issue
browser compatibility web components
generally have fairly good they're
starting to get more adopted but then
when you start to look at things like
the shadow DOM and the HTML templates
the browser support starts getting a
little bit more shaky particularly for
certain unnamed Microsoft browsers that
those of us in the enterprise world have
to support things get a little bit more
complicated and because of that you end
up you need to keep track of a lot of
polyfills and figure out you know which
features need polyfills for which
browsers and things like that so that's
when things you start to go down this
path of like Oh web components oh
there's right than myself it'll be easy
no problem and then you start you know
somebody's like well what about Internet
Explorer 9 and you're like I don't know
burn it all to the ground and so that's
where custom element libraries come into
play as with most programming concepts
just borrow somebody else's work so that
you don't have to write this all from
scratch so custom element libraries add
sort of a small layer of abstraction
over web components so that they can
worry about all the polyfills and all of
the compatibility issues and things like
that and maybe make the syntax a little
bit nicer so that you're not doing
direct Dom manipulation and having to
remember query selectors and things like
that so just gonna briefly go over a
couple of the biggest most popular ones
one of the most popular ones is called
lit element it's part of the polymer
project lit element is extremely thin
and lightweight people really love it it
has a number of great features it's very
declarative I'll show you the syntax
here in a second it's extremely
lightweight and it's also very internal
it works with a lot of other frameworks
and things like that plays really nicely
so people tend to really like using lit
element so and you can see the the
syntax for it is very familiar it's this
is like es6 with decorators and things
like that
not exactly typescript but it looks
pretty close to typescript and where you
just import things from lit elements and
you define your class and all you need
to do is decorate it with this custom
element decorator
and define a property and you have a
render function so it's very familiar
for for if you're coming from frameworks
or if you're coming from like c-sharp or
things like that helps to hide away some
of the more in the weeds Dom
manipulation kinds of things and then
you just throw it on the page with the
tag that you've defined and you've got
your name input there and you're good to
go
so that's lit element then we've also
there's one called spin cyl stencil is
created by the ionic team how many of
you've heard of ionic the yeah the
mobile platform for building hybrid apps
so they've also built this project
called stencil also very popular project
they've got a number of things going for
it it's also very simple also very
lightweight and also very good at cross
framework stuff one thing that I really
like about stencil is that you can use
JSX with it which is the way you write
templates in react so it's a very nice
modern way of writing web components the
one we're gonna focus on in the rest of
this talk is angular elements angular
elements is obviously from angular from
but it's actually an official google
package as part of angular and what's
really really nice about angular angular
elements is that it takes all the web
component stuff and but just lets you
write angular and let that angular just
become custom elements it's very nice
they handle a lot of things for you that
you don't need to worry about and that
makes it really powerful because along
with angular you're gonna get like rxjs
and everything you basically just write
regular angular and then angular
elements will translate that all into
custom elements which makes it a really
nice tool to use and then the other
thing that's really nice about angular
elements is because it's an official
google thing they've gone back and
they've added some hooks into angularjs
that we'll see later on that let it work
really nicely if you're doing a
migration from angularjs to angular
which is incidentally why you're all
here so we mentioned modernization
earlier and that's what we're gonna
spend
the remainder of this talk on and I
think we're gonna end up having a little
bit of time at the end for questions and
everything like that so no worries there
so of course we're gonna be talking
about angularjs to angular my hope is
that you can sort of zoom out one level
and take some meta lessons away of
moving any legacy project to angular
with angular elements because that's
certainly doable and then maybe you can
also extrapolate a little bit further
out to another metal level of just
moving like any legacy thing to any new
thing with web components you might have
to squint a little bit more to do that
in this case but we're gonna focus on
angularjs to angular and since we have a
number of angularjs to angular folks in
the room I'll slow down a little bit on
this section and go into a little bit
more detail on it so to get to give an
overview when it comes to migrating from
angularjs to angular there are
classically four basic paths to doing
that there is the rewrite path sometimes
known as the Big Bang I like to call it
burn everything to the ground and start
over
there's the ng upgrade path so ng
upgrade is a library written by the
angular team that is specifically for
migrating it's it's a bridge between
angularjs and angular and it basically
lets the two frameworks run side by side
and there's different methods that let
you for example downgrade your services
from angular to angularjs to let
angularjs use them and then go the other
direction where you can use for
angularjs services and angular you can
do the same thing with components you
can put an angular component in an
angularjs page and you can put an
angularjs component in a parent angular
component things like that very popular
method and we'll see some of the
downsides in just a second though and
then the third one is called hybrid
routing this one has actually a few
different flavors it can sometimes be
combined with ng upgrades sometimes not
the bottom line is that you're basically
using
each framework will be assigned to us to
a route like each framework will be
responsible for one route at a time so
you won't have the mixing of the two
frameworks on the same page
and you can accomplish this through
either having the server handle that you
know knows it knows that only serve up
the angularjs stuff or only serve up the
angular stuff or you can do that on the
client-side that's where you would use
ng upgrade and basically have to router
outlets where you'd have one router
outlet for angularjs and one router
outlet for angular and you have to do a
little bit of setup to make sure that
they don't overlap and things like that
that's also very popular one and then
the last one is angular elements which
we're going to talk about now
so yeah snap a picture of that these
slides will be available
I've also actually gave a talk at
angular finland last year that goes into
depth of each of these paths if you want
if you just google it's up on YouTube
angular Finland I think it caught I
called it like finding the right path
from angularjs to angular it's a little
bit more detail on each of these so
we're going to talk about angular
elements and the biggest question that
you probably have is like why would I
use like what's the scenario in which
angular elements makes the most sense as
the upgrade path I like to frame this a
little bit differently and think more
about like why wouldn't you use ng
upgrade because ng upgrade is like the
de facto upgrade path and ng upgrade is
fabulous especially when you compare it
to the fact that there's no migration
path from angularjs to react or view or
whatever else spelt or something there's
no there's no official path but you
basically just have to rewrite if that's
the direction you go so ng upgrade for
all its pros and cons is actually quite
an elegant solution to this problem so
why wouldn't we just go with that
so ng upgrade works really well in some
very specific use cases it's got like a
very it's got like a sweet spot and
these next couple of slides there there
are somewhat generalizations there are
exceptions to these rules depending on
your
application but I find by and large
they're pretty accurate so ng upgrade
works really well for small to medium
apps I like to say like basically it's
for apps that are small enough to where
you don't need a much more complicated
solution but they're big enough to where
rewriting them is a laughable idea like
their it would be silly to like shut
down your business for six months or a
year to rewrite the application from
scratch you have to be able to
iteratively migrate these applications
so usually in the neighborhood of like
hundreds of components probably not like
thousands of components although it does
happen I also works really well for apps
with fairly low complexity so one thing
angularjs was huge in line of business
applications probably a lot of you out
there are using line of line of business
applications for insurance companies or
banks or things like that where you're
doing these basically just massive crud
operations interacting with the database
and stuff like that and you have great
works really well for that you can just
replace your crud application pretty
pretty quickly with any upgrade and then
it also works very well if you've
modernized your angularjs to some extent
this isn't a requirement but if you're
already using things like es6 modules
with web pack if you've already switched
to component architecture maybe you're
using version 1.5 or higher most of
those aren't hard and fast requirements
but your life will be a lot easier with
ng upgrade if you've already taken some
time to at least get it to be more
current angularjs you're not using like
dollar scope all over the place and
dollar route watch all over the place
things like that so those are those that
sort sort of where ng upgrade works
really really well but there are some
flaws with ng upgrade and most of them
have to do with the fact that the two
frameworks are extremely tightly coupled
you get a lot of benefits from this but
there's also quite a few downsides
depending on the way that your
application works so two things that are
very tightly coupled with with ng
upgrade the
tendency injection system and the change
detection system and both of these while
they can allow you to do really cool
things like have your angular services
talk to your angular j/s app and vice
versa and sync some change detection
things there's a lot of cool things that
come with that but that also leads to a
number of pitfalls especially because of
third-party dependencies that you can't
control so for example complex UIs and
testing can become nightmarish with ng
upgrade when you're using the the linked
change detection so for example if
you're using how many of you are using
protractor for your end-to-end tests
nobody okay that's good I mean it's not
it's not neither good nor bad but but
protractor is an end-to-end testing
framework that was the official
angularjs and then testing framework and
it linked it hooks into the change
detection cycle unfortunately what
happens is that the angularjs change
detection cycle which is the dollar
digest or the digest cycle can sometimes
trigger a zone change detection in
angular which then triggers a digest
cycle detection in angularjs which then
triggers the zone detection and angular
so you get into this like infinite loop
it doesn't happen all the time but
especially with third-party libraries
and with in the end testing there's a
lot of nuance there that can cause the
change detection systems to get out of
whack so that's just one example
event-driven applications tend to have
this a lot and that's why the crud stuff
works super well the change detection
doesn't matter too much but in the event
driven applications they can I should
mention
since we're going a little bit deeper in
this subject that ng upgrade does have
an option for you to turn off that
linking of the change detection so if
you are concerned about that there's
actually another way to use ng upgrade
where it turns that off it just makes
the process much more manual you have to
trigger change detection yourself and
stuff so sometimes worth the trade-off
sometimes not depends on your use case
so angular elements where does angular
elements work best angular elements
works best with very large application
where the the time it would take to set
up the hybrid application within G
upgrade is not worth I mean sometimes
you've got these apps with thousands of
components and just like massive banking
applications and things like that that
it just won't make sense to use em G
upgrade also apps again with with very
high complexity very a minute vent
driven applications things like that and
then also apps that maybe are using
really old patterns
maybe angularjs 1.2 and dollar scope and
things like that where the time it would
take to modernize the angularjs code
just doesn't really make any sense and
that's when you can use angular elements
to just patch in angular so what does it
look like to use angular elements to
upgrade take a second 10 second water
break so there's roughly give or take
four steps to this process the first
step is the setup of the system of
angular elements and your legacy code
the next is sort of this apologize for
the cough I was sick a month ago and I
still have this cough that's just
lingering thought I'd be gone by the
time I gave this talk but it's it's not
and then so you take this process where
you basically rewrite your components
from the bottom up from angularjs to
angular as angular elements as web
components then should you need to share
state between the two frameworks instead
of using ng upgrade you'll basically
create these vanilla JavaScript services
and then wrap the two frameworks around
the vanilla JavaScript services and then
lastly once everything's been rewritten
to angular you'll convert your routing
over and then you'll remove the angular
elements library so what does it mean to
set up angular elements how does that
work and this is so normally when I when
I give tech talks I I really try to
avoid like hand
waving over details and because that
always really annoys me I really don't
like going to a talk where the speaker
is like this is easy like you just like
do this thing and it works and it's fine
and then you get back to your desk and
you realize like it's ten times more
complicated than you thought so I'm
breaking one of my cardinal rules here
simply because the ecosystem around
angular elements is a little bit
unstable right now because the angular
team has been working on this new
renderer called ivy and it involves
basically a complete rewrite of the
renderer of angular while trying to make
it completely backwards compatible and
Ivy will enable a lot of changes in the
internals of angular elements which will
also enable a lot of tooling changes in
it with angular elements so my goal here
is to give you sort of the building
blocks of the process but don't get too
lost in the details because it's
possible that over the next six months
or so the steps will get simpler so
that's my disclaimer but here's
basically how the set up is gonna look
you're gonna have this mono repo
situation here where you've got your
angular CLI project that has your custom
elements and then your angularjs project
that'll have your legacy code obviously
there's a lot more than index.html in
here but I've made it emitted like the
hundreds of JavaScript files for the
sake of simplicity because the index
file is the thing that matters here so
what you'll do is you'll have your
custom elements over here and you'll
bundle them all up using the angular CLI
and there'll be a bundle of your custom
elements and then you'll also have these
polyfills for all that backwards
compatibility that we mentioned and you
might bundle that into a separate file
sort of depends there's different ways
you can splice and dice this depending
on your use case but essentially that's
what you're gonna be doing not pictured
here is also the the dependencies that
that will be included in the bundle but
you'll have to ship angular as well as
you know things like rxjs in the browser
along with these custom elements and
that's some of the detail that is gonna
get refined over time when Ivy comes
they'll make it a little bit smarter
with deduplicating a lot of that stuff
and then you'll inject those script tags
into your angularjs index dot HTML and
that's how you'll be able to use the
custom elements on the page so the first
step after you've created the CLI
project that you'll house all of your
elements on you're gonna want to add
angular elements to it so you'll just
use ng add and add angular elements to
the project pretty straightforward
almost immediately after doing that
you're gonna want to check out this tool
called ngx build plus so the nice thing
about the angular CLI is that it's very
opinionated gives you a very
straightforward path on tooling for
angular but the downside of it is that
it's not as flexible as it could be and
so a community member named Manfred
steyr your ear over on this side of the
pond and how many of you know who make
Manfred steyr is he's a excellent
teacher in Austria and brilliant coder
he built this tool called ngx build plus
that basically extends the CLI to make
it more flexible you can customize the
web pack build and things like that
Manfred is is partnering with the
angular team right now and so I have a
feeling that before long this will
actually get wrapped up into the
official CLI but I can't promise that
it's not it's not really an official
thing but it's so useful that I have a
feeling it'll eventually just get
absorbed into the CLI so you can use ng
ad for ngx build plus and when you do
that you're gonna have all these new
options for the CLI one of them is this
ability to add this single bundle flag
and instead of the five or six files
that the CLI generates by default you
can split you can just put everything
into one file and there's there's a lot
of other options that that'll add you're
also going to need some sort of way to
get the the bundled custom elements over
into wherever your legacy code lives so
you could do this any number of ways
this is just an
sample with the CPR binary you could use
PowerShell you could use a bash script
it doesn't really matter but the idea is
that you need to take that dist folder
of the custom elements move it over to
wherever your legacy code is so that the
index dot HTML will know where it lives
and then just a quick note on the
polyfills so angular elements will
install a polyfill along with it but a
lot of times you'll find that the
tutorials around this subject just sort
of use the minimal polyfills so you want
to make sure if you are in the
enterprise space and need to support
ancient things or Internet Explorer type
things you might need to just check and
make sure that you've got all the
polyfills that you need and you might
need to add a couple more just because
most people in the tutorial world tend
to forget that the real world has to
still support some of these things that
are painful so then once we got the set
up then we need to go through this
process of upgrading the components and
that's sort of a just a one one by one
kind of process so we've got this
customers page here and on this
customers page we've got a customers
table and then inside of that or we got
the customers container and then we've
got the customers table inside of that
and we have this data flow basically of
the customer service passing data into
the customers component and then passing
that into the customers table component
so what we want to do is start with the
customers table component at the bottom
because it has the least dependencies
basically so to do that we're basically
just going to write an angular component
that's what's really nice about angular
elements so there's nothing special
about this angular component except that
you'll notice that there's no selector
tag and we're gonna come back to that at
the end of the talk but everything is
basically just has you as you would
write a regular angular angular
component you can see we have an input
for the customers everything is pretty
much the same but then in order to
actually translate that into an element
into a custom element we have to do a
little bit of setup
so in our ng module if you're using
angular 8
or earlier you'll need to add the
components to the entry components
angular 9 because of IV ditches entry
components it's no longer needed but as
of right now angular 9 isn't out yet so
pretty much all of you will will have to
do this until angular 9 comes out you
also add the component to the
declarations just like you normally
would in angular and then in the app
module is where you'll have to do a
little bit of setup with angular
elements so we need to we need an
instance of the injector and in our
module here and then we're going to
override the bootstrap function of the
module and that's where we call create
custom element which is from angular
elements you can see that we're passing
in the class the customers table
component as well as this object that
contains that injector reference and
then angular will basically use that to
package up a custom element for us and
that way we can just call custom
elements defined that's just the browser
API nothing angular about that and we
pass in the selector tag with the custom
element that angular created for us so
all in all quite nice because you're
just basically writing angular and then
you have this little bit of these few
lines of code and you're off to the
races
so earlier we saw we have this customers
input so how do we actually pass that in
and that's where this is another area
where angular elements is really nice
because they've gone back and in the
final release of angularjs which is
1.7.9 I think they've added these
helpers for angular elements so I should
mention that if you're not using
angularjs 1.7 the latest version my
friend James Henry who works for Narwhal
it was actually from here but moved to
Toronto he's made this library called ng
custom element because he was fighting
with his clients none of them were on
Inglis 1.7 so he had to go back and he
basically just replicated this
functionality of these helpers that
you're gonna see in a second so you can
check that out if you're not if you're
using one of the older versions of
angularjs so we're going to talk about
inputs and outputs here so the input the
way you can use an input with angular
elements is
engi prop and in the name of the input
so we have this input here of customers
and so then we add the custom element to
the page we've got our selector here
customers table see II sort of a best
practice to append the seee to the
selector just so that when you're going
back or the next person they know that
this is a custom element not just like a
plain angular component and then we to
pass that element in so this is I should
mention this is on the angularjs we've
thrown this custom element onto our
legacy code so our in our HTML like our
angularjs template or whatever contains
this new custom element from angular so
that's why we have ng prop customers so
we're passing in an input and you can
see that that dollar ctrl said should
scream angularjs to you so the dollar
control dot customers is coming from
angularjs being passed into this angular
element and then what about getting data
out with our outputs basically so four
outputs here's a different example we've
got a customer detail page we've got
this container component and then we've
got this discount type and the discount
type lets us lets the user edit the
discount type and then when they save it
that gets propagated up the chain to the
parent component so we've got a customer
detail component and a discount
component and they're passing data back
and forth basically and we want to be
able to convert that discount component
from angularjs to an angular component
so how do we do that well again the
component itself is just a regular
angular component I've omitted the
decorator here for the sake of space but
it would just have a regular decorator
just like the other one and so we'd have
an input for the customer discount
coming from that parent container and
then we'd have an output a regular event
emitter in angular for update discount
and then we could have our function that
just updates that emits that event with
the new discount and then sets the UI
state for us so to use that we use we
use something called ng on that's our
hook for angularjs so here we're using
the discount component the custom
element inside of our angularjs template
so we have our custom selector here and
then we have again ng prop with customer
discount notice that the underscore
there replaces I the camel case so you
can't do the camel case in these things
you have to replace that with an
underscore and then again screaming
angularjs dollar ctrl dot customer
discount that's coming from the parent
component being passed into the custom
element and then for our on our event of
update discount we're passing in the
function from angularjs for update
discount and passing in the dollar event
so when basically when that update
discount event in the custom element
gets triggered it will trigger the
update discount function on the parent
and pass in the event from the custom
element that's how that data will get
propagated up the chain there so now
we've got two custom elements and does
that mean we just have to like add all
this bootstrapping code every single
time well there's a nice elegant way to
do this a friend of mine named Jeff
Delaney is the first person who told me
about this he runs a YouTube channel
called fire ship and it's quite good but
his idea was to have an array of tuples
basically this is again an app module so
you're in your module file you have for
this array of tuples where you'll have
the component and the selector and then
you can just use a JavaScript for of
loop here and loop through that that
array of tuples and call create custom
element with passing in the component
and then call custom elements define
which will pass in the name and the
custom element and that way every time
you add a new custom element all you
have to do is add it to this array you
don't have to redo this custom element
define like 15 20 30 40 100 times in
your application you might want to also
group your custom elements into modules
so instead of having everything in app
module maybe you want to have them by
feature which will help you then once
the app is fully migrated
ditching angular elements you already
have everything grouped by feature so
sometimes you need to share data with
services sometimes you need to share
state and that that is not ideal
sometimes some you'd like to use just
like inputs and outputs like we've just
been talking about but sometimes it's
just unavoidable for whatever reason
when you live in the real world and so
I'm just gonna forewarn you this is
another thing that's gonna seem really
simple when I talk to you about it and
then when you go back and you're trying
to deal with like all these different
things in your real-world application
you might run into some complications so
just judge accordingly when you get back
to work and the reason is recurrence
we're gonna be off-roading with
JavaScript with vanilla JavaScript when
we talked about the two change detection
systems and zone Jas and Dollar digests
and all that and we're gonna use these
vanilla services and just totally bypass
all of that and try to wrap them in in
angular and angularjs so things can get
a little wonky sometimes but basically
we're going to create these vanilla
JavaScript services as Singleton's and
then wrap them inside of an angular
wrapper and an angularjs wrapper so that
we can use them inside the two
frameworks so here's an example of what
that singleton could look like so we've
got a property here called lazy shared
instance that's of the type customer
service our undefined and then we have
this class of customer service that has
a static method called shared instance
and basically when that static method
gets called it just was like hey is
there a lazy shared instance no there's
not okay well I'll create one a new
instance of the customer service and in
either case I'm just going to return
lazy shared instance and that's how we
make sure it's just like a very simple
way to create a simple singleton there
are many ways to create a javascript
singleton this one is one and so then
what we do is we would create an angular
version of that service and in that
angular service which would just have a
regular injectable we'd create a
read-only property of the customer
service and then we could create we
could call this shared instance method
on it and then we could do the same
thing in angularjs
this is using es6 you could also use
regular es5 and you're in your legacy
code but just for the sake of
readability do the same thing you have a
read-only property and you have the
shared instance method there and then we
could just call customer service get
customers in either framework so for
example in angular we would wrap that
promise into a creation method to turn
that into an observable because let's
assume that the vanilla one is using
like the fetch API or something and
returning a promise and then in
angularjs which already uses promises
you would just use the promise use dot
then call the vanilla service there's
just one caveat with angularjs remember
I mentioned the digest cycle we actually
need to call dollar route scope dot
apply because that promise is living
outside of the change detection system
it's not part of regular angularjs which
I know is a pain and at this point is
practically an anti-pattern but it's
just unavoidable in this scenario and so
I would encourage you to use the inputs
and outputs as much as possible just
because off-roading in the vanilla
JavaScript what the change detection
cycle can get kind of complicated and
the reason why you want to you want to
do this as sort of this idea of
indirection in your application we sort
of talked about this at the beginning
but you can think of indirection like
when you go to our restaurant you don't
run to the back of the kitchen and tell
the chef like what you want to eat you
order it through a waiter and this
provides this kind of layer between what
you want to eat and how the food gets
made so the chef doesn't need to know
anything about the customer and the you
the customer don't need to know anything
about how to make the food and this
allows a lot more flexibility there's
going to be many different customers
again it's going to be many different
orders and that's the power of
indirection and incidentally indirection
is the core foundation of the redux
pattern which in angular gets translated
into ng rx and the reason I bring this
up is because when we go back and look
at the use cases for these angular
elements migrations we talked about
large acts with high complexity and
these legacy patterns
and coincidentally those first two the
large apps with high complexity are also
fantastic use cases for n gr x and the
Redux pattern and so there's a good
possibility I'm not going to say always
and that you should do this but there's
a good possibility that you're gonna get
down the road with your large angular
application and realize that you should
be using ng Rx for state management we
can't spend we can't spend a lot of time
on this but feel free to come talk to me
afterwards and things like that if you
want to talk about Redux and ng rx and
migrations and things like that I gave a
talk at ng Vikings last year with Mike
Ryan on this very thing of using ng rx
to share state between angularjs and
angular so it's a very popular pattern
okay so just finishing up the upgrade
here let's say you've already done all
the component updates you need to go
back and add selectors so I omitted the
the selector from earlier but one good
practice would be to have a commented
out selector because you remember the
selector is getting defined when you
called custom elements that define so
that's why you don't have the selector
here in the decorator so you might want
to have commented out selectors so that
then once you're done migrating you can
just uncomment it and you're good to go
lastly you're going to go back and
switch all your routing if you were
using angularjs for routing you'll
switch that over to angular there's
there's not much to that other than it's
just sort of a grind of doing it but I
would leave it to the end I wouldn't try
to have both routers going at the same
time if you can help it and then lastly
you'll drop the angular elements package
I got to make sure I say that cuz one of
the times I gave this talk somebody was
very confused that I I say at the end
like just drop angular elements because
he thought I meant like delete all the
work that she did so you're gonna get
rid of the dependency of angular
elements basically which means that you
want to clean up your modules get rid of
all that bootstrapping code uninstall
the package and the tooling around it
and then you can probably get rid of
most of the polyfills that you added for
the custom elements you might have to
keep some of them for just for the sake
of angular but the specific web
component stuff you'll be able to get
rid of
okay so I've hit you live like so much
information in the last 52 minutes
luckily this is recorded and I'm always
available being a GD e and stuff like
part of my job is to help you with these
things so please always feel free to
come talk to me but the we talked about
how web components are this this idea of
reusable custom elements with the
functionality encapsulated from the rest
of the code then we looked at sort of
the anatomy of the vanilla custom
element with the selector the class and
the options object and we talked about
how that gets a little complicated when
you start getting into the more advanced
features of web components and making
sure that they're compatible with
browsers which is what leads to the
creation of those component libraries
like stencil and lit element and angular
elements then we looked at the elements
upgrade strategy piece by piece where
first you've got the setup process then
you've got you're sort of just grind of
upgrading all the components one by one
and then you've got this idea of sharing
state with vanilla JavaScript services
and wrappers and then you basically just
convert the routing and remove the
elements and that's basically it there's
a number of resources out there on this
subject there there's even more than
what I've got here so if this is
something that you really go down the
rabbit hole with get in touch with me
and there's there's number of things for
example the the consulting firm Narwhal
has been doing this process with Capital
One the bank and they've written about
this process
I think it's on medium they've got
articles about this process of using
elements for upgrading last year at
ng-conf they also gave a talk about this
process where they go through some of
the pitfalls and they looked at ng
upgraded things like that so that's a
good resource just Google like upgrade
Capital One or something like that you
can find that there are a lot of other
like more broad
resources on web components and things
like that if you just start going down
that rabbit hole on on Google but I
think I think that's basically it the
slides are at NDC - London or they will
be within the hour or so so just Sam ji
m / NDC London and you can follow me on
Twitter at Sam julene send me a message
whatever I also have Ott's zero stickers
up here feel free to grab a non zero
sticker and that is basically it with
five minutes back of your life so thank
you so much we have a few minutes for
questions if anybody's got a burning
answer otherwise you can all take off
and people can stay behind
looks like the verdict is everybody take
off it's a good vibe I don't blame you I
don't blame you